after the divorce this was an awakening  I realized that I really needed to kind  of figure out what was going on with me  in order to move forward it's easy to  lose yourself when you're only in your  young 20s and you're just doing what's  expected of you and not really thinking  about your own needs and I think I think  the divorce was the best thing that  could have happened to me  and for my children as well because I  don't think I was being a very good  mother at the time either I wasn't  making good choices I realized that so I  had to deal with myself first because we  ultimately have to take care of  ourselves before we can help others  right where are they now all new  Saturday 10/9 central